when a person gives himself heirs because he can
understand and interpret the books of chrysippus
say to yourself if chrysippus had not written
obscurely this man would have nothing about
which to give himself heirs but what is it i
want to learn nature and to follow her i seek
therefore someone to interpret her and having
heard that chrysippus does so i go to him
but i do not understand what he has written i seek
therefore the person who interprets chrysippus
and down to this point there is nothing to justify
pride but when i find the interpreter what remains
is to put his precepts into practice
this is the only thing to be proud about
if however i admire the mere act of interpretation
what have i done but turned into a grammarian
instead of a philosopher the only difference
indeed is that i interpret crucifix instead
of homer far from being proud therefore when
someone says to me read me chrysippus i blush
the rather when i am unable to show him such
deeds as match and harmonize with his words
epictetus was a teacher of stoic philosophy and
so he he moved in circles in which people did
talk a lot about stoic philosophy and he also
probably had a lot of students who came to him
who had done some previous reading so you notice
that he talks here about chrysippus chrysippus was
sometimes called the second founder of the stoic
school in part because he wrote so much and he
also wrote a lot in response to critics of the
stoic school sometimes attacking them sometimes
defending the stoic principles and so to read
chrysippus was in in many respects for ancient
people to study stoicism and so epictetus um
wants to counsel us against what we can call the
difference but not between book smarts and street
smarts the way people uh like to take like to
talk but between sort of an academic theoretical
treatment of stoicism and then actually making it
part of your life actually practicing it so he
says when a person gives himself heirs because
he can understand and interpret the books of
chrysippus say to yourself well that's because
chrysippus wrote obscurely and so it's difficult
to understand him similarly you know we have a
kind of distance with with respect to epictetus
he wrote in in koine greek and it's trans
translated often by these kind of oxfordy you know
uh types and so it may be a little bit difficult
i shouldn't myself for example put on ears in
providing you this commentary because um all
i'm doing is is sort of bridging a gap right
if it was super easy to read epictetus and to
understand everything that he was saying no need
for commentary right so he goes on and he says um
what is it that i want i want to learn nature
and to follow her so i seek there for someone to
interpret nature and having heard chrysippus does
so i go to him this is why we read philosophers
this is why we study with with philosophy teachers
because we think well they've got something that i
want it's not necessarily the the end product
it's something that will get me there and so
i go and i read chrysippus because i've heard this
chrysippus guy knows a lot of stuff he can explain
things really well he's you know he's going to
help me out right and so i read them and then i
say oh i i don't understand what's going on here
i can't understand what has been written so then i
go and find as he says somebody who can interpret
chrysippus and then he says down to this point
there is nothing to justify pride there is nothing
to justify making a big deal out of oneself
and then he says when i find the interpreter
the interpreter what remains is to put his
pur his precepts into practice this is the only
thing to be proud about if you want to be proud
be proud about the fact not that you've studied
the philosophy not that you've got a diploma in it
not that you have uh you know whatever marks
or distinctions you want be proud about the
fact that you can actually apply it in a real way
not just in a theoretical way not just in a maybe
down the line i'll do this sort of thing sort of
way but in a real way so he goes on and he says
if however i admire the mere active interpretation
what have i done i've turned into a mere
grammarian a person who studies not just grammar
but literature that's what grammarian meant back
then a person who studied it and taught
it perhaps rather than being a philosopher
so he says the only difference is that i interpret
crispus instead of homer far from being proud
therefore when someone says to me read me chris
i blush when i when i'm unable to show him such
deeds is match and harmonize with his words that
is really a interesting thing to say at the end
we talk a lot about you know different figures
or or different authors or even you know
filmmakers or things like that how cool they are
about you know what characters they develop and
show us the real test for all this is whether
we can't incorporate that into our own lives
otherwise it's just sort of an academic
exercise and if you want to do academic
exercises that's fine stoicism is about more
than that whatever principles are set before
you stand fast by these like laws feeling that
it would be impiety for you to transgress them
but pay no attention to what somebody says about
you for this is at length not under your control
in this very short chapter number 50 epictetus
tells us two things that are not really connected
with each other one of which is very rich in
implications and the other of which is is a
repetition of things that we've heard a number
of times so i'm going to start with the second
he says pay no attention to what somebody
says about you for this is at length not
under your control and this is a reminder that
we don't have to be concerned with how other
people view us because that is something that we
don't control it's largely a product of their own
filters and their own you know aims and desires
and you know how their desires and aversions flow
out into the world we should think of other people
as essentially being in the same condition as
ourselves except not having had the message that
that stoicism is able to provide them with and
is usually thinking that they're doing all right
that they've got things figured out even though
they're usually quite a a mess right so we don't
have to worry about what they think about us now
the thing that's more uh rich in implications like
i said here is this very short passage which is
what whatever principles are set before you
stand fast by these like laws the greek term
is nomos feeling that it would be impiety
for you to transgress them that it would be
it would be not only wrong in a moral sense but
that there would be something like you know the
bottom dropping out of the universe so you know
when somebody uh goes against what they consider
to be holy uh that which provides meaning running
throughout the entire existence of the person
when you go against that that's more than just
going against a social opinion or even against
you know what you know to be right or wrong
unless you've got a very very highly developed
sense of right or wrong and now notice that he
talks in terms of laws now why is that important
in part because we should look at these these
principles that are given to us the ways that
we ought to behave that have been discussed
throughout the rest of this this work as being
something like rules that we don't get to play
loose with we don't we don't get to interpret and
say well uh it doesn't apply to me in this case
because this is a this is a special exception and
you know so what would be an example of that if
it's bad for you to lose your temper at somebody
at all as is what the stoics think then you don't
get to say oh yeah but they said something mean
to me or they let me down or they cut me off in
traffic it's bad for you and you shouldn't do it
and so you know what is what does the rest of the
law say okay acknowledge that you screwed up and
then don't just say oh i'm gonna acknowledge
it and then move on do what you need to do to
fix things fix things with the other person if
that's what needs to happen and also fix things
within yourself so that you can quit making that
same mistake if you allow yourself to be upset
because some person who promised you a job
doesn't come through with the job you know
these are things that happen all the time realize
that this is one of these cases where you need to
to apply the distinction between what's in
your power what's not in your power don't
say well on this occasion i get to go out and
commiserate with my friends and complain about how
unfair the process is because it really was more
unfair this time if you're going to treat stoicism
as something that you can kind of pick and choose
it's not going to be as successful for you now
epictetus doesn't say that you know you can't try
that go ahead and try it out see how that works
and see if you actually make any progress
epictetus is saying if you do want to make
progress you need to treat the principles that
you've got to work with as if they are laws that
apply all the way across the board and then
follow them how long will you still wait to
think yourself worthy of the best things and
nothing to transgress against the distinction
set up by the reason you have received the
philosophical principles which you ought to accept
and you have accepted them what sort of teacher
then do you still wait for that you should put
off reforming yourself until he arrives you're
no longer a lad but already a full-grown man
if you are now neglectful and easygoing
and always making one delay after another
and fixing first one day then another after which
you will pay attention to yourself then without
realizing it you will make no progress but living
and dying will continue to be a layman throughout
make up your mind therefore before it is too late
that the fitting thing for you to do is to live
as a mature man who is making progress and
let everything which seems to you to be best
be for you a law that must not be transgressed and
if you meet anything that is laborious or sweet
or held in high repute or in no repute remember
that now is the contest and here before you are
the olympic games and that it is impossible
to delay any longer and that it depends on
a single day in a single action whether progress
is lost or saved this is the way socrates became
what he was by paying attention to nothing but
his reason in everything that he encountered
and even if you are not yet a socrates still you
ought to live as one who wishes to be a socrates
even though it was written over two millennia
ago this advice that we're getting in chapter 51
is always timely and why is that the case well
whenever we read it it always does apply to us
and it's about time and about you know
the progress of our lives and about
the fact that we've already wasted enough time
frittering it away not doing what we ought to do
and now is the time to decide or we can put it off
some more and maybe see what happens that's our
choice we we do have a free faculty of choice but
epictetus says here that no it is time to make a
decision and notice towards the end how he frames
this he he talks about the olympic games and this
is sort of like the pinnacle of athletic success
so this is talking to each of us as if we are
going into the olympic games and
and we are the olympic games of life
whether we become the kinds of people that we
were originally intended to be or whether we
continue on with the kinds of people that
we've wound up being and we've made ourselves
that is that is a the most important thing
in the world to epictetus so he says remember
now is the contest here before you are the
olympic games it is impossible to delay any longer
it depends on a single day and a
single action whether progress is lost
or saved and we'll come back to that in
in a little bit but i wanted to stress
this this this metaphor of the olympic games
because it shows us that he he considers this
to be the most important thing your business
success your love life your circle of friends
how your body looks those are minor compared
to whether you get yourself straight
about who you are what kind of thing you are and
what you have the potential to be and then do it
it doesn't do any good to know all this and
then not actually practice it any more than
it would for an olympic athlete to go and you
know stand there with all the other swimmers and
then the gun goes off and they just stand there
thinking about i really like swimming swimming
is so cool you've got to jump in the water and
move right so let's let's start where he starts
how long will you still wait to think
yourself worthy of the best things
that's a really interesting question we have a lot
of self-help people who push and also in you know
other other areas as well they push this oh you
have to think of yourself as as worthy of goodness
and then the universe will give it to you they
often have a mistaken conception of what goodness
is and about being worthy is epictetus thinks that
we're worthy of living in accordance with nature
having our our for our faculty of choice uh in
accordance with nature making ourselves into
the kinds of people that we have the potential to
be without conflicts within ourselves dealing all
right with the conflicts that arise in the outside
world happy unfettered free that is a possibility
for us that is better than anything else that we
could be provided with that's better than winning
the lottery that's better than the you know person
that you find who you're totally attracted to
that's better than statues being erected to you
that's better than being invited to give a set of
prestigious lectures that's better than all of
these sorts of things according to epictetus
not that those aren't you know nice things
but they'll certainly be put in in fuller
perspective if you're actually happy in your
life so he says how long are you going to wait
how long are you going to wait to not transgress
against distinctions set up by reason this is
another key theme in this passage what is going
to guide you towards that it's your faculty of
reason of rationality what is distinctively human
in you what you have and what you need to develop
you know it's not as if your faculty of reason is
perfect it's not like you know plug-in software or
hardware that you just pop into your motherboard
you need to work on it you need to develop it
that's why education is so vitally important so
he got he goes on and he says look you've received
the philosophical principles which you ought to
accept you've been studying stoicism you've got it
in your hand now um you've accepted them at least
in a certain sense you have you have taken them in
what sort of teacher then do you wait for who
are you waiting to solve your problems who are
you waiting to give you the advice about how to
proceed why are you waiting around for somebody
else to give you the guidance you have the
resources you need so he goes on and he says
what sort of teacher do you wait for that you
should put off reforming yourself until he arrives
now it that's not to say it's not helpful
to have a teacher or interpreter my hope
in producing these videos is that you know my
years of studying epictetus help you as you study
epictetus and try to apply this in your life not
to say that that any of that doesn't help right
but this is the great thing about stoicism you
can do it whether you're on a desert island by
yourself or in the middle of a metropolis as
a lonely person who doesn't know anybody who
just got plunked down there because i don't know
your flight got canceled or something like that
right you don't have to wait for somebody
else to come along and solve your problems
for you you've been given what you need so
he says all right you're no longer a child
but already a full-grown person and at the
time that that i think most of us read this
there may be some people who are in fact uh
you know adolescents who are watching this
and maybe his advice doesn't fully apply to you
you know we know for example that impulse control
is something that continues to develop as we
get older um you know up till 25 now we've we've
realized although science may tell us something
different in years down the line and so you know
this may not apply to everybody although certainly
one can begin to practice stoic philosophy
as a young person but for those of us who are no
longer children and adolescents what's our excuse
why aren't we putting it into practice
what is it that we're waiting for he says
if you're now neglectful and easy going and
always making one delay after another and fixing
first one day then another after which you'll pay
attention to yourself what's going to happen now
think about this people do this sort of stuff you
know they create an intention oh it's new year's
i am gonna finally get my life in order i am gonna
start like getting up every day and meditating
and you know doing some visualization exercises
and reading my way through the end caribbean
or the discourses or seneca's letters or
whatever and i'm going to really put it
into practice people make all sorts of plans
like this oftentimes i think that the plans uh
substitute for the actual doing because it's a lot
easier to sit there and drop all sorts of plans
and schemas than to do the hard work of looking at
yourself and saying i don't like what i'm seeing
i need to fix this this is disgusting or this is
revolting uh maybe my aversion needs to be turned
towards the fact that i do this and i have these
you know reactions that i don't want to have right
but people sit there and they make plans and they
talk and talk and talk and you know they don't
actually do anything um it's not stoicism too that
that's a you know peculiar in this respect you can
think about saint augustine in his confessions he
talks about a period of years and years and years
where he's he's you know basically ready to make
the plunge into living a fully christian life
and he says you know this famous prayer god give
me chastity but not yet not yet because i still
want to enjoy myself a bit there's time for that
later and then at a certain point you're like this
is this is nuts i i shouldn't be behaving this
way if i really think that this is the best way
i should be going full steam towards it i should
be as people say all in so he says what's going to
be the the cost if you are neglectful in this way
you make one delay after another and you just make
a bunch of plans and talk talk talk talk talk well
without realizing it you will make no progress
but living and dying will continue to be a
lay man throughout a person who is not on the
philosophical path a dilettante you will not make
any progress as a matter of fact the only progress
you'll make is probably in being better at lying
to yourself about the progress that you're making
and putting out a better face of a dilettante
to other people so they think that you're hot
stuff and that you're actually into stoicism but
if you're not doing it there's no benefit to you
and the longer that you keep on delaying he
doesn't mention this here but delay itself
can turn into a habit which then you have to break
as well that becomes even tougher so he says look
now is the time make up your mind before it is
too late that the fitting thing for you to do the
right thing for you to do the appropriate thing is
to live as a mature person who is making progress
make a choice to to actually grow up as
we say and and behave like a mature person
take responsibility for your own feelings
take responsibility for your choices past
and present take responsibility for your thoughts
for what it is that you filter situations through
for the stories that you've told yourself take
responsibility for all of that and then he says
let everything which seems to you to be
best for you be a law which must not be
transgressed here's that conception of law again
if you think that you should do some sort of
action like you know you decide that meditating
every morning is what you need to do then do it
make it a law for yourself quit talking
about it quit you know uh making plans
to do it quit reading benefits about it in
you know articles and stuff like that do it
and if you stop doing it then take yourself
to task say i broke the law that doesn't mean
you need to be punished or anything but get
yourself back on track quit making exceptions
so he goes on and he says if you meet anything
that is laborious or sweet or held in high repute
or in no repute remember now is the contest
if you meet the things that we we encounter
as challenges you know laborious things that
are going to require a lot of work on our part
that we're type we you know we tend
to be averse to we put that off
sweet temptations right that can draw us in that
can get us to do things that we shouldn't do
we have to stand up against that held
in high repute held in low repute that
shouldn't matter to us now is the time that's
why i said this is very very timely advice
because anytime you read it you can apply this
whether it's you know two millennia ago whether
it was you know yesterday when you first read
it or you know and then ignored it whether it's
today when you're watching this video and saying
oh i should go back to that re-read that passage
it applies to us at at every time now is
the contest so he goes on and he says um
it's impossible to delay any longer it depends on
a single day in a single action whether progress
is lost or saved again this is why we want to
make these these precepts into laws for ourselves
because we as soon as we start to backslide
as soon as we start to give in we start losing
the progress that we've made and we start
to fall back into the natural tendencies
the old habits of thinking which are actually
tendencies against nature against what human
nature ought to be but i say natural in a
different sense here these tendencies to
to justify ourselves to tell us that it's okay
for us on this one occasion that you know we we
can fix it tomorrow or that we weren't really
doing it we were just trying to do this instead
all these things are excuses that we give if we
want to really follow along the path of progress
we can't cut ourselves any any slack in this
respect you know when we can cut ourselves slack
is after we've screwed up and then we don't have
to tear ourselves down but we giving ourselves
slack doesn't mean we don't get right back on the
treadmill and start exercising again we have to
look at things honestly we have to be true
to ourselves and true to reason in our
self-examination so he goes on and he says this is
the way socrates behaved socrates became what he
was and socrates is a great hero to the stoics
by paying attention to nothing but his reason
his rationality in everything that he
encountered socrates got himself killed
by practicing philosophy and why did he practice
philosophy because that seemed more rational to
him to do than to do the opposite and he tried to
reason with the judges he didn't convince them his
friend actually bought off the jailers and said
hey we can transfer you to another city and you
can do philosophy there and you don't have to die
what did he say to credo let's think about this
let's reflect on this let's reason about it
and his reasoning took him to the end of no
it's better to obey the laws and to stay here and
be executed socrates made such an impression on
people because he did in fact use his rationality
he followed it he didn't you know make exceptions
and say well my feelings are saying this
so i'm going to ignore what reason tells me
that would lead them to question his feelings
which we ought to do our emotions are not always
the not not even often the best judges or guides
or interpreters of the situations that we're
in so he says even if you're not yet a socrates
still you want to live as one who wishes to be a
socrates if you want to be a stoic that's what it
what it means to be a stoic to want to live like a
socrates to want to live like a hero to want to
live as the olympic victor of life and the good
news is this is in all of our power our bodies
i'm not up to competing in the olympics i'm not
even up to competing in you know professional
or or even amateur sports of any sort right
but we can do this with our our choice our
faculty of choice our rationality any one of us
can live a fully human life it's up to us
to decide to do that and the time to choose
is when you become aware of that not down the
line in some distant future that may never
happen because you can get hit by the bus tomorrow
you could get sick tomorrow do you want to reach
the end of your life and say oh yeah i always
had the intention of trying to live this way
never really did it kind of sad about that or
do you want to be able to look back over a time
back to the time where you finally said yes
i need to make a decision and stick with it
you